[Applauso]
quando gli amici dei miei bambini mi
chiedono che lavoro fai
io rispondo io faccio gli occhietti ai
robot per essere precisi
io cerco di inventare gli algoritmi che
siano la parte del cervello di un robot
che controlla gli occhi la vista
importantissima per noi noi esploriamo
il mondo con la visione con la nostra
capacità di percepirlo pensate che il 30
per cento dei nostri neuroni sono
dedicati alla visione solo il 4 per
cento al tatto pensate anche che c'è una
parte del nostro cervello che è
espressamente dedicato a riconoscere i
visi e che il primo viso che un neonato
impara una delle primissime cose che un
neonato impara a riconoscere il viso
della mamma perché dalla mamma dipende
la protezione dipende il cibo e quindi
la nostra capacità di percepire è
fondamentale per capire il mondo ed è
per questo che dobbiamo cercare di dare
queste stesse capacità percettive robot
se vogliamo che diventino veramente
parte della nostra vita che ci aiutino è
però vedere più che percepire facciamo
una demo ho bisogno del vostro aiuto
alzi la mano destra
chi pensa che questa sia una tazza chi
pensa che sia una tazza continua a
tenere sulla mano destra e adesso invece
chi pensa che questo sia un portapenne
alza la mano sinistra potete tener
lazzate tutte e due
vi siete arresi tutti
che cos'è che ha fatto che è successo
qui quando io vi ho fatto vedere questo
oggetto voi lo avete riconosciuto come
una tazza perché tante tante tante volte
voi avete bevuto un caffè un the o
qualsiasi sia il vostro liquido caldo
preferito da un oggetto come questo
liquido caldo perché io sto tenendo
questo oggetto dal manico perché le
tazze anno il manico perché le vogliamo
usare sono dei contenitori che vogliamo
usare per mettere del liquido caldo
dentro lo alla mano deve stare distante
perché non mi voglio scottare però un
contenitore e qualche volta sicuramente
l'avete visto usare o lo avete usato
come un portapenne perché è un
contenitore posso metterci dentro le
cose posso metterci anche l'acqua posso
metterci anche una piantina perché no
allora che cosa sto dicendo qui che la
percezione di questo oggetto non mi dice
tutto rispetto a quella che è l'essenza
di questo oggetto
noi capiamo quello che vediamo non solo
sulla base di quello che percepiamo ma
lo capiamo anche sulla base di altre
modalità di quello che facciamo con
questo oggetto
e allora nel nostro cervello cosa è
successo quando io vi ho mostrato questa
tassa è successo che noi abbiamo dei
modelli che si possono definire meta
modali formati da tante modalità a cui
la percezione è quello che ci fa fare
clicca e dove ci agganciamo però poi ci
sono tutte queste altre informazioni che
dipendono molto da tutto quello che noi
possiamo fare con questi oggetti da
tutte le azioni che abbiamo compiuti con
questi oggetti ed è così che li magazine
chiamo nella nostra memoria è così che
si capisce quello che si vede ed è
questo tipo di rappresentazioni meta
modali di cui abbiamo bisogno per far
capire il mondo e robot per farli vedere
come vediamo noi è però non basta ancora
dobbiamo fare un passo in più dobbiamo
andare oltre
vi racconto una storia
questa è una foto dalla al mio album di
famiglia di una pasqua di tanti tanti
anni fa io sono la bambina che sta
guardando con un amore sconfinato l'uovo
di pasqua perché io è la cioccolata mi
piaceva mi piace è così e così però
anche una bambina disciplinata quindi ho
aspettato fino alla fine del pranzo per
spazzolare luogo e poi non è finita lì
perché oltre a essere molto golosa io
sono anche sempre stata molto vanitosa
mi piaceva non mi piacciono i vestiti e
questa carta era bellissima tutta
luccicante collocata e così dopo aver
mangiato nuovo ho preso questa carta
mela sono paludata intorno e mi sono
presentata così in salotto io non avevo
mai visto nessuno usare la carta di un
uovo di pasqua così nessuno mi aveva mai
detto che con la carta di un uovo di
pasqua potevi farti un vestito però
avevo visto tanti tessuti avevo capito
avevo visto che con i tessuti si fanno i
vestiti avevo visto la mamma al mare con
il pareo che assomiglia molto a questo
oggetto prenderlo e farsi investito e ho
riconosciuto che questa bellissima carta
colorata mira queste stesse proprietà di
flessibilità e quindi che cosa ho fatto
io
io ho immaginato che con la carta di un
uovo di pasqua si potesse fare anche
quello che si può fare con un pareo e
l'ho fatto e mi sono vestita questo è il
punto questo è l'essenziale oltre ad
essere capaci di capire il mondo con
rappresentazione che vanno al di là di
come lo percepiamo con rappresentazioni
meta modali noi siamo capaci di
immaginare noi siamo capaci di andare
oltre quando vediamo qualcosa noi siamo
capaci non solo di pensare a quello che
è di capire di comprendere quello che ma
anche di immaginare quello che potrebbe
essere questo è uno dei grandi trionfi
dell'intelligenza umana ed è oggi uno
degli enormi limiti dell'intelligenza
artificiale
io sono sicura che voi avete sentito
notizie di robot che fanno concerti
questi robot eseguono perfettamente
esattamente le azioni i gesti che gli
sono stati insegnati dal loro maestro
se questo maestro e un grandissimo
artista il concerto sarà meraviglioso
ma sarà esattamente esattamente quella
singola e unica interpretazione
confrontate questo con quello che sono
capaci di fare e di essere umani
pensate a un'orchestra jazz di musicisti
che si incontrano che suonano insieme
per la prima volta che mettono il loro
talento insieme e creano al momento
improvvisando una musica meravigliosa
mai sentita prima
questa capacità di immaginare questa
capacità di andare oltre questo è uno
delle grandissime sfide che
l'intelligenza artificiale che la
ricerca in questo campo oggi cerca di
affrontare non è facile dobbiamo passare
da un mondo analogico ad un mondo
digitale
quando io lavoro sulle immagini le
immagini sono fatti di pixel quindi
tutto è discreto e quello che dobbiamo
fare è scrivere e scrivere programmi e
scrivere algoritmi che riescano a
catturare almeno in parte quello che io
vi ho raccontato per farlo abbiamo uno
strumento da un paio di anni e da cinque
anni per la precisione il di planning
sono degli algoritmi che cercano di
simulare il comportamento del cervello
umano si implementano delle funzioni che
assomigliano i neuroni che assomigliano
alle sinapsi collegamenti tra atene
neuroni e questi algoritmi vengono
chiamati algoritmi ha grande capacità
perché sono algoritmi in grado di
gestire milioni e milioni di dati nel
mio caso di immagine queste queste
immagini sono solo il cibo se volete
sono la benzina che mettiamo dentro
questi algoritmi che riescono a sono
specie di di dis premi dati li mettiamo
dentro e riescono a distinguere il
rumore dal segnale quello che è un
dettaglio da quello che è essenziale e
siccome nel web ci sono tantissime
tantissime immagini ci sono tantissimi
dati per cercare di costruire
rappresentazioni meta modali soprattutto
nel caso in cui non abbiamo esempi
concreti nel mio gruppo di ricerca i
miei vandali e mi va bene ci siamo detti
ma perché non proviamo a insegnare i
robot insegnerà a imparare dal web in
fondo quando noi non conosciamo qualche
cosa che facciamo adesso fuori il
cellulare e cerchiamo sul web perché non
anche per i robot
questo è un esempio di quello che noi
facciamo qui vedete il braccio robotico
abbiamo chiesto a questo robot di
sparecchiare un tavolo dopo che avevamo
fatto colazione nella memoria dei robot
c'erano vari oggetti c'era la tazza
c'era la banana ma non c'era il vasetto
di miele e quindi robot ha percepito che
ci fosse qualche cosa sul tavolo ma non
era in grado di dire cosa fosse e quindi
è andato a cercare sul web cosa ha fatto
ha preso una foto e con questa foto ha
trovato tante altre immagini simili
tante altre percezioni simili e dopo un
po ha iniziato a notare che queste
percezioni simili che trovava sul web
erano molto spesso associate a una
parola vasetto di miele e così ha
imparato il nome di quell'oggetto e con
il nome di quell'oggetto ha potuto
cercare anche altre informazioni ha
capito che è un oggetto che è composto
di parti perché ha un coperchio e quindi
quando il robot deve andare a prenderlo
non è una buona idea prenderlo dal
coperchio perché se non è avvitato mi
porto via coperchio il vasetto resta e
li ha imparato che c'è un certo peso che
si può aspettare quindi la forza che il
braccio robotico deve utilizzare per
tirare sul vasetto sarà di un certo tipo
ha imparato che un oggetto rigido non è
come il cartone del latte quindi quando
preme quando la mano si chiude il
controllo tattile deve essere di un
certo tipo
eccetera eccetera e vi faccio notare che
questa informazione che sul web e
troviamo
sotto forma di testo quindi un simbolo
noi la impariamo con le azioni con la
nostra esperienza e siamo capaci di
click toglierla dalla nostra esperienza
e renderla simbolica e accessibile a
tutti e così dopo aver imparato tutte
queste cose
il robot ha scoperto che questo oggetto
misterioso è un vasetto di miele ed è
stata in grado di prenderlo e continuare
a sparecchiare la tavola
abbiamo costruito una rappresentazione
meta modale di un vasetto di miele a
partire dal web e con l'immaginazione
che cosa facciamo con la capacità di
immaginare quello che noi ci siamo
immaginati è perché lo facciamo venire a
robot delle allucinazioni in maniera
legale solo legale allora questo che
vedete qui è una mela allucinata abbiamo
preso delle foto di mele dal web e
abbiamo insegnato a robot a immaginare
come sarebbe stata questa mela in tre
dimensioni perché l'informazione che io
trovo sul web sono immagini sono a due
dimensioni ma io ho bisogno di capire la
profondità la forma dell'oggetto e
quindi a partire da questa da queste
immagini siamo riusciti a dall'ucina re
la forma
questo è un piccolo risultato però in
realtà per me un passo molto importante
fatemi fare un altro esempio ora vedo
quello che riesco con queste luci vedo
tutti i vostri visi io non vedo il
dietro delle vostre teste
però ho visto molte molte volte delle
persone e quindi sto assumendo che il
dietro della vostra testa sia sferico
ora magari laggiù dove non vedo c'è un
alieno di due re stellari con una
bellissima testa il ricciolo e quindi li
sto sbagliando però se siamo tutti
esseri umani qui la testa e rotonda
questo noi lo facciamo con continuamente
quando noi percepiamo in maniera
incompleta per proseguire in qualsiasi
sia l'obiettivo che dobbiamo avere per
avere un modello del mondo noi
completiamo con quello che è più
probabile
ma questa capacità di completare e
capacità di immaginare perché di solito
io vado con il più probabile ma chi
disegna in venti personaggi di guerre
stellari cerca l'improbabile e allora se
noi qui abbiamo trovato la strada per
avere una mela probabile forse in futuro
da qui noi troveremo anche la strada per
una mela di guerre stellari
mettendo insieme tutti questi pezzi
siamo riusciti ad avere una r1 che
impara dal web dei fiori questi sono
tutti gli oggetti che robot ha già
imparato a riconoscere e quando vedete
queste barre che si alzano e che si
abbassano questo segnala la confidenza
che ai robot in quello che vede non
assegnare un nome a quello che vede
adesso riconosce il guantone da forno e
vedete a volte a delle esitazioni e
adesso vi mostriamo il fiore e allora
bisogna che impari che ancora e va a
cercare immagini sul web simile a quella
che a vista e ne trova tante anche il
nome fiore quindi si può aiutare è
quello che facciamo per aiutare il robot
a calare questa conoscenza in quella che
è la sua esperienza del mondo nel
momento in cui gli serve usare questo
modello è che prendiamo tutti questi
fiori ritagliamo dalla foto
automaticamente lo facciamo online tutto
quello che non è fiore e lo mettiamo in
uno scenario che è molto simile a quello
che i robot vede intorno a sé per
aiutarlo a riconoscere i fiori che può
vedere intorno a sé
ecco il modello di firenze ha imparato
siamo ancora molto molto lontani da
poter dire che possiamo riconoscere
qualsiasi oggetto però stiamo facendo i
passettini in questa direzione
quando questi passettini porteranno ad
aver percorso tutta la strada
avremo dei robot che alle feste di
compleanno dai nostri bambini
prenderanno le lucine dell'albero di
natale e cercheranno di farsi belli per
la festa siete tutti invitati
grazie
[Applauso]